[Music]
drex here from drexfactor poi sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
today i want to talk about anti-spin
flowers and specifically how to clean up
some of the bad habits that i see people
tend to pick up with them i've got five
specific things that i see pop-up
frequently with both my own students as
well as people that i see posting online
and you know what
i'll bet they can help you out with your
anti-spin flowers too before we dive in
though i just want to give a quick shout
out to the friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys spin balls and
ultra poi for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard les machinski and
becca beckham thank you all so very much
for your support for my work and my
mission
anti-spin flowers are one of the most
distinct and recognizable poi tricks of
the modern era they're almost like the
kick flip of poi we create anti-spin
flowers when our hand traces out a
circular path and the poi spins in the
opposite direction in the same plane
they're frequently but not always
performed in wall plane in front of us
but some variations are performed at our
sides in wheel plane instead they're
kind of a rite of passage for many poi
spinners inspin flowers may be a little
bit more intuitive and easier to learn
but anti-spin flowers have a much more
exciting appearance with sharper
narrower petals and are a must-have for
many if not most tech poi tricks i've
taught a lot of people how to perform
anti-spin flowers over the years and
because they can be so challenging to
get down it's also pretty common that
people pick up some bad habits as they
learn them so i want to share with you
five tips based around the most common
mistakes that i see people make that
will hopefully help you improve your own
anti-spin flowers too one note in this
video i will be focusing on anti-spin
flowers with four petals i know there
are other variations but i wanted to
keep things focused on the most common
type of antispin flower here if you'd
like me to do a follow-up on triquetras
or other anti-spin flowers leave me a
comment and let me know if it's your
first time here check out my playlist on
learning poi during the covid 19
pandemic and get started with poi on the
ground floor and don't forget to
subscribe so let's dive in tip number
one explore volume since most of us
start learning poi with butterflies and
weaves we get kind of used to keeping
our hands within a comparatively small
area which is not that shocking because
between typing cooking or using a remote
control that's really a space within
which we're likely to keep our hand
movements anyhow but it also does not
serve your flowers at all frequently
when we keep our arms cramped into a
tight space it can be hard to tell for
sure that we're even performing a flower
but if we allow ourselves to truly
explore the volume around ourselves all
of a sudden those flowers take on a
completely different character this is
going to take a little bit of training
to get comfortable with but there are a
couple things that you can do to get
yourself more comfortable with it first
and foremost practice this in a space
where you have a lot of room to stretch
out so you're not worried about hitting
things
then wrap the poi all the way up around
your hand and trace out a circle with
your arm completely outstretched
try letting the poi out spinning in the
opposite direction and see if you can
maintain the feel of having your hand
completely extended even as the poi is
spinning
this may take a little practice to get
used to but it should start to bridge
this gap another possibility involves
visualizing the poi in a slightly
different way to do this drill imagine
that there's a giant diamond in front of
you that extends from above your head to
far out to your right side down near
your hips and then far out to your left
as you spin the poi try to move your
hand directly between each of these
points in a straight line as this gets
to feel more comfortable try to bow
those lines out a little bit and work to
keep your arm extended the whole way
through one thing to look out for here
is making sure that you don't pull your
hand back inward in between petals
lots of people are able to reach out for
each petal but feel like they have to
bring their hand back in toward their
body center in between the petals
work to keep your hand as far away from
body center in between the petals as it
is at the tip of each petal tip number
two reach high on the top pedal this one
is actually so common that i'm not the
only one to make a video about it a lot
of people will find once they start
playing with anti-spin flowers that
they're able to explore the volume to
either side of their body as well as
down below but struggle to get their arm
extended across the top of the flower
which again is completely understandable
it's pretty rare that we have a reason
in our everyday lives to reach high
above our heads so this is something
that feels very outside the norm for us
and can take a little getting used to
this is made even more complicated due
to the fact that many of us are
practicing in indoor spaces where we may
or may not have clearance to fully
extend our arms and poi straight up i'm
six feet tall or 183 centimeters and my
ceilings are only eight feet tall i bump
my poi against the ceiling constantly so
how can we get used to reaching up high
for that top pedal even in a small space
well here's a couple suggestions the
easiest option is honestly just to work
on practicing your anti-spin flowers
outside where you have all the vertical
clearance in the world
don't be shy about reaching up for those
top petals it can feel a little alarming
to have the poi falling from such a high
point directly toward your face so make
sure to move your hand off to the side
immediately after performing that top
pedal to absorb that drop and keep the
rest of you in a safe space but if you
have to practice indoors it might not be
a bad idea to drill your anti-spin
flowers with your tether choked up a
little shorter it's not unusual for me
to wrap my tether around my index and
middle fingers or hold it in such a way
that the tether goes across the palm of
my hand with this arrangement in mind
really stretch to hit that top point
perhaps dare yourself to try and tap the
ceiling without fear and see if that
gets you to reach a little more as
you're going over one final note here is
to try and make sure that you're not
shrugging as you go high see if you can
get your hand to reach up without taking
your shoulder with it it's both better
for your shoulder and it creates a more
pleasing line with your arm tip number
three hitting points not beats another
one of those bad habits that we pick up
when we start spinning poi with
butterflies and weaves is the tendency
to unconsciously keep the poi spinning
at a regular beat this isn't a big deal
when we play with tricks in a small
space but as soon as we open things up
with flowers and especially anti-spin
flowers that tendency to focus on
keeping the poi spinning at that regular
beat frequently comes at the expense of
getting proper pedal placement or having
conscious control over how the poi spins
at all all anti-spin flowers are what i
like to refer to as minimal beat
patterns that is they look better when
the poi is spun as few times as possible
through them but how to gain control
over that regular poi beat
honestly i think that could be an entire
video in itself and may eventually
become one but in this particular case i
think it's best to go back to
fundamentals namely training with linear
isolations linear isolations involve
moving our hand from side to side of our
bodies and letting the poi head poke out
once as the hand moves to either side
since my dominant direction of spin is
clockwise i have my poi head pop up my
center line as i move my hand to the
left and drop down my center line as i
move my hand to the right
in both cases i want my hand to kind of
sneak past my poi
switching from the poi leading to either
side to then allowing my hand to lead to
either side this can take a little bit
of practice to get down not the least of
which because you have to wrap your head
around the fact that even though the poi
pokes out when it goes up
it doesn't actually complete a beat when
that happens once this drill begins to
feel natural you can move your hand with
the poi head up as the poi head goes up
your center line and down as the poi
head goes down your center line and at
this point you're performing an
anti-spin flower but more importantly
you've learned some control over when
the poi does and does not complete a
beat while doing it if you'd like a
longer explanation of this process with
a lot more detail i did a whole tutorial
just on this alone that i'll go ahead
and link to in the description or up in
the cards if you're watching on youtube
tip number four don't add extra pedals
let's be real spinning the poi in the
opposite direction that your hand is
traveling in feels super weird it's not
unusual for people to try and make it
feel a bit more normal by spinning the
poi one extra time at one of the petals
i frequently find this happens in the
top petals and it can be linked to not
having conscious control over the beat
of the poi as i outlined in the last
section
people want to beat at every pedal so
badly that they'll add one even if it's
not supposed to be there fixing this one
involves kind of a leap of faith as well
as changing a bit of what we're looking
for at each petal of the flower first up
there's a phrase that i learned in dance
that definitely applies here you are
always arriving think that when you get
to your top left bottom or right that
that isn't your destination but merely a
stop along the process as soon as your
hand arrives at any one of these points
but especially the top one it's already
moving on to the next point if you want
to keep track of the downbeats think of
this as
down right
and left
down right and left with the and
happening at that top pedal another way
to train this out involves abandoning
the idea of beats entirely and focusing
instead on the poi tagging points far
away from body center so instead of
thinking of the poi as having a top
pedal left pedal bottom pedal and right
pedal think instead that you're trying
to tag away from you up left down right
with the poi only allowed to tag each
spot once
if you see it spinning around to tag
that spot again move your hand quickly
away from it even if you miss the next
pedal it'll at least begin to build
muscle awareness of staying at each
point no longer than is necessary before
i share with you my final tip for
improving your anti-spin flowers if
you're getting a lot out of these tips
i've got more of them for you you can
download my free pdf guide on my top
five tips for improving your poi
spinning over at my website at
drexfactor.com
these tips cover everything from how to
improve technique to fun exercises
that'll test your poi spinning
capabilities in new and creative ways
download that guide at the link down in
the description or the card that just
popped up if you're watching on youtube
and now for my final tip tip number five
keep those side pedals high kind of
similar to how we sometimes don't extend
our arms upward at that top pedal lots
of people also keep their side pedals at
their waist near the bottom pedal the
problem here is that the bottom petal
and side petals all just kind of melt
into each other resulting in a pattern
that isn't very pretty and sometimes it
can be confusing whether the intended
pattern is even an antispin flower at
all this may take us a bit out of our
comfort zone but the answer really is
here to realize that our side pedals
aren't just at our sides but are
actually at shoulder level for many
people shoulder level is about as high
as they're used to their hand reaching
so it feels like a high reach but when
we spin anti-spin flowers with poi we
have to think of shoulder level as being
the middle rather than the top of our
flowers
not just because it looks better but
also because many of the transitions we
go into from either side of the flower
such as plane breaking won't work if
they're below shoulder level to achieve
this really focus on arriving at
shoulder height for each of your side
pedals check yourself in a mirror if you
have to it'll probably be a bit of a
shoulder workout at first but the
resulting shape is absolutely worth it
in anti-spin flowers centered on the
shoulders so beautiful and those were my
top five tips for improving your
anti-spin flowers which of these tips
was the most helpful did you discover
that you had a habit you didn't know
about before watching the video would
you like to see me do another video like
this one on other kinds of flowers let
me know by leaving me a comment
[Music]
this video would not be possible if not
for the wonderful support of all of
these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support do you like my videos do you
like my flow sessions vlogs reviews
combos and more i'm on a mission to
bring poi spinning and flow arts to the
wider world and help people connect with
their brains and their bodies so help me
do it head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of rewards and
help me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like more tips tutorials and more for
beginner poi tricks like flowers you can
check out a playlist of other videos
like this one that i've linked to down
in the description or up on screen if
you're watching this video on youtube
thanks so much for watching don't forget
to subscribe and make sure to get out
and flow today wherever you happen to be
it's good for your body and for your
brain take care and i'll see you again
soon
peace